I will be talking about
a topic that Marine also tastes in his
talk what's going on in Group logging
for maxat or maximum satisfability what
have people been doing what are we doing
and what should we be doing in the
future
and in many ways this is a very nice
talk to give because Marine already did
about half of it and Mark did the rest
but I'll see if I can fill in something
you can finish early now yes
okay so here's the problem statement
we've discussed this briefly on Monday
for me maxat is the problem of
minimizing a suitable and expression
with positive coefficients Boolean
variables subject to a set of process
and now
Jacob tells me that there are people who
won't sort of believe that this is maxed
out that they want to see hard and soft
losses but I can assure you this covers
every single one of the Max and
definitions that I am aware of
having said that there are two specific
things in this talk which will actually
actually require me to create this
objective as a set of units of Clauses
like this
so we have positive variables there
setting them to True will give us cost
this corresponds to falsifying at loss
containing the negation
but for the most part I could provide us
to think of it as a linear objective
subject to a set of clauses
uh as we've heard many times this week
already maxid is thriving and
competitive optimization paradigm
I will be mostly talking about the field
of set-based solve Maxwell solvers for
complete solving that means solvers that
aim to find the provably optimal
solution
but there's also interesting stuff going
on in what we call anytime solving we
heard two talks already and also
incremental solving where you want to
sort of solve many optimization problems
efficiently
each year we see sort of papers come out
with interesting applications of maxette
and also improvements in solar
techniques
okay so this is hopefully the slide that
I can go fairly quickly on just heard
Bart explain what is the certificate of
an optimality optimization problem get a
solution
you know that it's optimal and you
formalize this concept of their isn't
isn't going to be any better Solutions
and then improve a contradiction on that
what do we want to do this
as is the case with many other paradigms
method algorithms today are very
complicated they use a lot of
interesting and difficult techniques
I'll show you I'll name drop them in a
minute
and this leads to them being fairly
error prone this is not unique to max
out in a way
already in 2016 we had a solver
participate in the evaluation that was
the only one claiming optimality on an
instance
an error which was noted only the next
year when another solver was able to do
a bit better and find an even lower cost
solution
more lately working with this
proof logging we've discovered bugs in
commonly with maxat solvers where
they're performing reasoning
without unsound reasoning but reasoning
that led to simplification that happened
to align with Optimal Solutions on every
single one of our benchmarks so all of
the results were correct but the
reasoning was not and this was called
byproof logging
all right so when you sweep a whole lot
of interesting details under the rugs
you can represent set basement solving
like this
and I'm using the sort of proof by
reference dump to argue that this is
what people have been doing
and this is the most effective way of
solving maxite instances arising in
other applications
the idea here is that we use the cdcl
sad solver incrementally we've heard
nice talks about about how they work
we query that solver on some kind of a
working instance I'll say a bit more in
a second about the Alternatives here
and then based on the result we either
modify the instance
or are able to conclude that yes now we
have the optimal solution the minimum
cost solution
and for this talk specifics are not that
important what you should sort of know
is that there are many different ways of
doing it
the most natural way is what we call
solution improving or sat onset search
here you ask the solver find me a
solution that has lower cost than what I
already have if it gives you one good we
tighten that constraint give me a better
one
because and so on and so on and so on
until the third solver says no no there
are no better Solutions than we know
it's optimal
you can also do lower bounding search
you can use the fact that these set
solvers can also give you
uh unsatisfiable course that in this
context can be thought of as conflict
Clauses over your objective variables
so you can ask it is there a solution of
course zero okay for any interesting
instance it will say no and it will give
you a small conflict loss over your
objective variables which you can then
use in different ways in order to relax
the instance and allow slightly more
cost to be incurred in subsequent
iterations
the two main ways of doing this at the
moment are so-called so-called core
guided algorithms
and the implicit hitting set based
algorithms horror guided algorithms put
more work on the chat solver
and have have it decide like
increasingly complex course
well the implicitly said solver sort of
externally compute suggestions on what
could be the minimal Solutions and the
subsolver and checks them hopefully Nina
will talk a bit more in detail about
this at least the core guide It's always
tomorrow
so the take-home message here for proof
vlogging is that there's not one set
based Max set algorithm that needs to be
pre-loaded these three exhibit somehow
fundamentally different kinds of
reasoning which means that any kind of
proof logging we want to develop should
be able to support like different ways
of
uh finding Optimal Solutions
and the situation gets even more
complicated when we start looking at
solvers actual implementation of the
implementations of these algorithms
there are many effective access solvers
nowadays and most of them Implement not
only a single one of these algorithms
but different kinds of complex
combinations of them
and to make the life of the proof logger
even more difficult they will also use a
number of really sophisticated
heuristics on top of this basic
algorithm and these are definitely
non-trivial uh to proof log
at this point you might be sort of
thinking
the solvers use stat solvers effect
extensively Marine just spent a whole
lot of time talking about house that's
all set proof logging is very well
understood and effective
can't you just use that can't you proof
of proof login Max set with the help of
the techniques that exist for chat
the short answer is no
the better answer is the proof logging
that exists for sat is going to play a
significant part improve login Max ad
but it's not going to be enough
uh we've got for a concrete example we
can look at a specific technique that
this especially this correlated solvers
are using nowadays
we have an objective with three
variables
and an instance with six clauses
and from this we would like to deduce
that the cost of the instance is at
least four
this is what Max that people would call
either intrinsic at most once or mutexes
but me people would call sort of Click
constraints
addition human argument for why this is
so is that it's fairly easy to see that
we can at most put one of these B
variables into false with one we have to
put the restroom and thus we will incur
cost at most the sum of two
of the minimums here
but to proof lock this we could use a
set solver and if that's essentially
what the method solvers do in the first
step the first step is to figure out
fairly trivially
these explosives entail pairwise binary
Clauses over this this artificial
solvents this is not sort of difficult
in any way difficult
but now to get from this to arguing
about why why this means that the cost
must be at least four that's where sort
of the limitations of the proof plugin
that exists in modern set solvers and we
need to be able to do something else
make this same point in another way we
can go back to the figure I just showed
you
what do we need for proof plugging a
Microsoft solver that looks like this
on the one hand we need to be able to
handle that side of the charge this is
the reasoning performed by a set solver
and this is very well understood today
very effective all is good
and we also need to be able to handle
this handle this side
so we need to be certifying that the
modifications that this algorithms make
to the instance are sound and result in
the set solver checking what we wanted
to check
only when we can do both of these then
we can pre-plug that there is Max at
solver
very quick question is there also not
max out reasoning going on on the left
to decide that you end up in the opt
found branch and that you
kind of yes yeah you could see it that
way I sort of figured the termination of
these solvers is usually when this had
solver either says set or answer
depending on the algorithm so yes
you could see that as a form of
Microsoft reasoning and this is the
stuff you were saying that
and that
you need to prove that what this app
solver is doing then is deriving a
contradiction on there doesn't exist a
better solution
and this is a formal acceleration but
yes
it's more of a high level question you
call it sat based Market but maybe it is
better to call it answered based market
right because you're going from we also
have solution improving search which is
sort of which is you're coming from the
above so you're querying the set solver
and it will say with improving
increasingly lower cost solution because
there is there any non-sub-based Market
I mean there is a last year we had a
fairly interesting solver in the
evaluation that was based on this sort
of combining close learning with branch
and bound search which
had some interesting potential it's not
as mature as these techniques yet but it
and hence I left it outside of this talk
but yes there exists but not much
[Music]
it was a fairly good
spot for questions because we're sort of
in halfway next we're going to be
talking about group plugging methods
so at this point
what you should have sort of hopefully
got them from this is that third base
map said it's a rich implementation
Paradigm there are many different
algorithms
posing like unique challenges for proof
vlogging and we use sad solvers
extensively
and the proof of these we need to sort
of be able to handle the set reasoning
combine it with reasoning of costs and
reasoning over this intricate heuristics
questions are different
so for the heating based solvers and
then you have a set of course and you
know the heating set so while just set
of course together with one more unsat
call of the thought solvers don't so you
have a question yeah so I know that you
do some other abstract course but if you
don't do more fancy are you good proof
look and then we get into this
discussion with transferiato can also
have an opinion on are you pre-flogging
the results or are you proof vlogging
what the solver is doing so the solver
is not sort of it's not doing the final
answer call so hence you would get
approved for your result being correct
but now we also want to sort of develop
methods that are able to capture the
actual reasoning being performed by the
solver and hopefully this is why we were
able to catch the bug in in the or that
it's over
used
all right
so this is that was the introduction
slash halfway point of the talk
and for the rest I will go over sort of
what is being done what kind of work
does there exist
I will roughly go through them in the
order of increasing applicability for
capturing sort of this General Max set
algorithms that are being used with
techniques
compared to some place for vlogging
Microsoft plugging is definitely not as
mature so there's not as much to this
first I found some fairly early work
focusing on sort of checking the set
proofs the important context here is
that this is before it was so well
understood and so automatic this chat
set checking as it is today so even then
people people were sort of almost asking
what you were asking can we check the
proof of the set solver in the last call
but then you need at the very least you
need to be sure that the set solver the
instance it is solving is saying what
you want it to be solving because you
might have a bug in how you do your
encoding that that checks
um and then there's also some earlier
work on sort of this dplt style State
transitions that simulate dpll algorithm
algorithms and they also have this
optimization criteria and and and can
provide certificates
and might be applicable to these branch
and bound solvers but not I not at least
directly to this sub base over
six there are some extensions of Tableau
calculus from sat to maxat
this is the first of the two things
where I need to be able to do weighted
soft process
here we have an example instance
consisting of three heart Clauses and
two weighted soft process
and if you now want to do a proof of
this instance with this Tableau calculus
you start by putting your
input process here and then you start
working through each and every one of
them applying very very well defined
rules to end up with something like this
here for example this first step comes
from this Clause here so you have them
close with an r that results in a
splitting
then you keep on doing this and whenever
you have a branch
that has contradicting literals you
derive the empty class
um to make a difference to that notice
that in maxat
even when we get the empty class we
can't stop because we want to know what
the cost is so you have to sort of
expand the entire way and once you've
done that you can then check which
branch of your tree has the lowest
weight of these empty Clauses and that's
going to be your optimal cost
this is approved this is a proof for an
Optimum cost
but it doesn't really capture reasoning
done by any any of the solvers I am
aware of
next I was a bit sort of going back and
forth on whether whether or not to
include this but seeing the seeing as we
have had this reading group on this PR
clauses
and red clauses I wanted to say that you
can also extend these redundancy Notions
that Moraine was talking about the max
ads in maxat you say that a clause is
redundant if it preserves the optimal
cost of the instance
we've sort of done this with mate I'm a
student ended up with a Max set notion
of red Clauses and even a maxed notion
of propagation redundancy
and shown that similar similarly to what
happens inside you can use these
redundant sheets in oceans as basis of
the correctness of many of these
reasoning techniques does lifting them
from set to max out in a correct way
and we've also been able to show some
fundamental mental differences in what
they can do to Solutions
adding both these types of process can
can change
the set of solutions but only adding red
Clauses will not change your Optimal
Solutions while adding PR Clauses could
this is interesting but for developing
this toward proof logging run into a
similar problem that we were talking
about earlier checking the cost
conditions that are required for this is
challenging in an only closer closure
based system
then we have max resolution this is a
very full slide and the specifics of
this rules doesn't don't really matter
for this talk
this is an extension of resolution from
sat to Max apps you get three different
rules and this is the second thing that
I need to have weighted subclasses for
and an important difference between this
and sort of resolution percent is that
Max in Max up resolution you remove
premises from your instance so you apply
a rule you get this you get the
resolvent and then you get these
compensation Clauses that make sure that
your your Solutions are preserved and
then you remove the premises
this is a complete sound and complete uh
proof system for maxat
in the sense that if you have a set of
weighted hard and soft clauses you can
always do a sequence of Microsoft
resolution steps
to end up in something like this another
Formula F star which is satisfiable and
all of the solutions to this f-star will
be Optimal Solutions to to what you
started with
and you derive the empty Clause that has
caused the unsatisfiable empty class
that has caused exactly to the minimum
cost of your instance
and this gives you a proof for Max set
and there's even but the challenge is
then to figuring out what are these
steps
there is a work on sort of taking a
proof that the Zep solver gives you
turning that into a Microsoft refutation
by short resolution refutation but as
far as I know there are people who are
better this year than me but as far as I
know there's no sort of way
to always do that without maybe blowing
up in size
but Microsoft resolution has
been used as basis for some corrugated
algorithms that are actually used and
also as basis for for like accept proof
systems just interesting work
and finally surprising no one interested
Bart talk
for half an hour however people you can
do optimization so it's not very
surprising that it can do max out as
well
I won't repeat much of what Mark was
saying you take your classes and you
view them as linear inequalities this is
sort of negation now means one minus X
and once you do this
and
access sort of cutting plane reasoning
the sort of fundamental challenge that
these other systems had
of reasoning with the costs comes almost
for free now you can have the cost as a
suitable and expression and you can do
cutting PlayStation reasoning on that
where are we when it comes to uh
Brooklyn inside Place Max set with very
PB
for the solution improving search there
are specific solvers already existing
and sort of papers on How to certify
this the pseudable line encoding is the
extra thing you add to the software
saying give me a solution that's better
than what you already have
and there are no sort of fundamental
problems with with doing this for any
kind of software you want to you just
need to do the encoding maybe at this
point specific depend might require a
bit of work but it's not kind of have to
be done
or by the church we actually very
recently had a submission on the
so-called oll algorithm which is the
most commonly used algorithm in in
Coronado Max art
showing how that can be pre-flogged and
Andy we'll talk about that on Monday
into that seminar so come there if you
want to hear the nitty-gritty details on
how to use very PB in order in order to
prove load maxit
that's all right just that's a very
interesting sort of challenge it does
not exist yet and the main challenge
here is that the hitting set the way in
which we just decide how to form modify
the instance
is computed by amip solver so proof
logging IHS as solvers as they exist
today seem to receive the recover some
kind of plugging of mip which I know
there is work on but I also think
there's nothing concrete yet
but
right so what are the future directions
what are the challenges as I mentioned a
specific sort of maxat challenges we
have really good Saturdays I mean really
good sad proof vlogging how do we
combine that effectively with the more
like higher level backup reasoning about
costs
there's work to do still to be done
there are no fundamental limitations in
covering more more of the heuristics
that are used
but it still needs to be done and sort
of the elephant in the room is this
are using the technique so pre-flogging
them comprehensively will require some
kind of plugging as well
then if we want to be people to actually
use it it would be nice to have sort of
good libraries and and not for solver
developers to do a lot of extra work to
add them and we have to do a lot of
extra work to edit but hopefully we can
make it easier
and of course it would be sort of nice
also to go beyond complete solving we
might consider situations if you have an
incomplete solve anytime solver that
gives you a lower bound you might want a
certificate that your solution is
definitely going to be in this case
and this sort of algorithms that are
being used are by no means exclusive to
Max said token was talking yesterday
about an unsatisfiability based ASP the
overl algorithm I mentioned was actually
first proposed for asp
the same algorithms exist for PBO CP
etc etc
so
by sort of figuring out how to proofload
in the new Mac set the hope is to also
be able to provide them in these other
paradigms even though they're a unique
even though every single Paradigm
proposes also its unique challenges as
we'll hear next for CPU
all right so four points I don't
remember if if it's plus four or five
that you should maybe take home from
this Max that is cool Max ad is
effective you should be using max out at
least trying it
uh large there's a large diversity
available algorithms and heuristics so
don't just look at who won the
competition because that might not fit
well with your solar your your
benchmarks
try them out
for vlogging step-based Max ads is not a
direct extension of just pre-plugging
that you can't just proof plug is that
solver and be done it's not yet as
mature as that proof vlogging even
though there's been some reason very
promising developments
and there are many interesting future
challenges
to be solved
thank you very much
about five minutes here for questions
any questions
so um
for example in your solver you have this
step of guessing core like abstract core
how would you proof Vlog that
it's a very specific question uh for the
mid part
of I don't know but for the solver part
yeah there's some interesting uh
connections between abstract course and
the kind of force that that forgot its
Albert are extracting already
so uh for the CNF what goes into this
set CNF solver I think it's going to be
very similar to how we're how we're pro
plugging our LL
but MIP is still sort of I don't know
but I guess you're guessing
yes okay we're guessing uh the inputs to
that yes and that doesn't matter what we
need to proof log is the core so we can
guess whatever we want and then we use a
sad solver to show that that leads to
them sort of uh implied clause and this
implication needs to be shown but what
the gas itself does not because there
are no
because we can guess whatever we want if
you get a Core it doesn't matter what we
guessed
so they were mentioning at the beginning
of your talk that you were able to show
that two solvers were buggy and they
were given the ultimate solution
uh were you able to learn anything from
that so I mean by looking at the error
did you have the opportunity to come up
with an incomplete solver
now we're on a very sort of technical
level but the reason is the bug arose
from a few specific implementation
choices in those solvers that are sort
of non-standard and
I don't think they actually would
probably do anything concrete we can
talk offline in detail if you want to
okay I think it's a very technical low
level technique okay yeah sure yes
any other questions oh okay
so so just to remind I think that for
any time algorithms which do not claim
completeness you don't really need to
proof loading because
there is a solution right yeah
certificate but if they do claim
completeness then yeah that is one thing
but I was also thinking about sort of an
anytime algorithm it could be
conceivable that it could give you a
lower back
and then you could prove a little bit
lower
my solver does this I see so you could
have solver some shows are complete and
then yeah complete is one thing
absolutely
right yeah anytime incomplete if you
just want to have a good solution then
there's no need for actual profiling
that's true because you just look at the
solutions
this is yeah this is not a point yes so
it might help you find bugs so you do
you think you're always doing something
and then it's actually not to have a bug
so you're still getting Solutions but it
might be nice to know that your children
all right thank you
Jeremiah thank you
and now it's Matthew
oh thank you very much on uh thanks for
all making it of the day I'm gonna try
and bring together some things from
yesterday and some things from today uh
talking about pre-flogging